something like 50 percent of the light
emitted in the US by light fixtures goes
up straight in the sky and the amount of
money which just nearly referred to as
right now the estimate is about three
billion dollars per year is converted
into photons that go up in space simply
because of a poor design there's
definitely a trend and a recognition of
going green and being less pollutant and
yet we're wasting like three billion
dollars a year on lighting up the sky
which is very harmful for our own health
which has been now clearly detected to
be very very bad for our health having
strong ambient nighttime lighting it's
very bad for for nature for ecosystems
shielding all the lights aiming them
down where they are supposed to be
lighting and dimming them to proper
levels and not over lighting this is it
and it has not been achieved